they came to Germany claiming to be
refugees from Syria's Civil War now it's
claimed they committed crimes against
humanity during it specifically multiple
murder torture and other serious
offenses in that's Alaska latest
biometric leaders the defendants are
accused of having been members of
Syria's general Secret Service the
accused is believed to have been head of
an investigation unit which was
responsible for Damascus as head of the
unit he is believed to have been the
leader of investigation officers and
personnel in a prison in which
systematic torture occurred the older of
the two defendants defected from
President Bashar al Assad's forces in
2012 before coming to Germany two years
later he was subsequently identified by
Syrian refugees living here
he and his co-defendant were arrested in
February last year in bringing this case
the German authorities are applying the
principle of universal jurisdiction of
certain of their laws regarding serious
criminal offenses effectively allowing
them to prosecute individuals who are
not German whose alleged offences did
not take place in Germany and whose
alleged victims are not German the war
in Syria has now gone on for more than
nine years human rights organizations
have left the calls for such trials to
take place they believe this is a
watershed moment this is La Vie in fact
that's my vc short ones days he's up for
test begins persitz above all importance
that this child is taking place I think
a lot of people including our clients
have waited for a very long time that
this finally takes off it was a huge
challenge for them to step out of the
shadow and to speak about these crimes
for the first time ever and Thursday's
hearing neither defendant indicated what
plea they will enter to the charges
given the presumption of innocence for
all defendants it is for the prosecution
to prove its case investigators have
compiled a long list of witnesses
prepared to testify
Dominic Kane al Jazeera Berlin